[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bien sûr ce soir il n'y aura
qu'une lauréate qui repartira heureuse
est chamboulée mais pour les autres
croyez en mon expérience en la matière
ça va être horrible
c'est un véritable échec dans la vie
d'une femme on se sent salie moche
abandonné perdre un césar c'est raté
l'équivalent de cinq entretiens
d'embauché mais en robe du soir
perdre un césar c'est pénible sur le
moment et c'est pire dans les jours qui
suivent
c'est une baisse signifiante de la
libido mais chez votre partenaire perdre
un césar c'est lire du mépris dans les
yeux de ses enfants de l'inquiétude dans
les yeux de son agent et de l'ambition
dans les yeux de son chirurgien
plastique perdre un césar c'est comme
perdre un ami
s'ils tentaient que cet ami souhaiterait
petit et très compact mais je tenais à
dire aux merveilleuse actrice qui sont
nommés ce soir
si vous ne l'avez pas cela ne veut pas
dire que vous êtes moins bonne cela veut
dire que vous êtes fini
[Applaudissements]